there is an example with the exponential
function let's work through this I can I
can feel some yawns in the back but
let's work through this because the next
one is an example which uses this
particular case okay so let's say we
want to find the antiderivative of e to
the K X K is a constant not equal to 0
okay so in that case you know so here
it's not we're not using the power rule
that we used in the past what was the
what was the derivative of K to the K
times e to the K X from the last session
anybody remember so if F let's say F X
is k e to the K X then the derivative
was what
okay let's just do eating mr. KX oh
that's right guy I in that case it's k e
to the K X right okay so e to the K X is
derivative of this inside function x
itself okay derivative of e to the x is
just e to the x and the derivative of
this inside function is k to k e to the
K X now so suppose that you have suppose
the derivative is actually e to the K X
okay you know that the exponent is not
going to change right that's the feature
of the exponential function when i took
this derivative the exponent didn't
change okay unlike those polynomial
functions so that's going to go back to
something like e to the K X ok but if I
had each of the KX and I took a
derivative i would get k e to the K X
but I don't have a que here so I'm going
to have to divide by K right so that's
going to be 1 over K
everybody with me know okay so let me do
that again you realize that if I were to
take a derivative of e to the K X then
I'm going to take this coefficient put
it in front and keep the exponent the
same okay so i would go from e to the K
X take a derivative I'd get ke to the KX
exponent stays the same and i'm taking
the coefficient in the exponent and
putting it in front but but here I've
just done it this way so as to help
remind you that this is a function and
this is its derivative it could be a
little F so there would be no difference
if I had simply done the important thing
here is that this is the prime of
whatever that function is ok so when I
take a derivative of an exponential
function the exponent stays the same and
I take the coefficient from the exponent
and put it in front so I know I'm being
told that i have a derivative equal to e
to the K X and I have to find its
antiderivative ie the function which
when differentiated gives me this as its
derivative I know that for exponential
functions the exponent didn't change so
I know that that antiderivative has to
have the term e to the K X there will be
no change in the exponent but I look at
this and I think well if I would take a
derivative with this I would end up with
ke to the KX I'd end up with a k in
front I know I didn't end up with a k
here so there must have been something
here which when multiplied by K
gave me a one well what is it that when
multiplied by K gives me a 1 1 over K
right okay yeah so you wouldn't do that
in other words you wouldn't you would
take the K and multiply it by the
coefficient but not the KX okay so just
look at this is the sort of the simple
example if you have e to the K X when
you take its derivative you're going to
take the K and put it in front and leave
e to the K X here because you have what
you have to do this is if you apply the
chain rule you know we didn't spend much
time on this but if you apply the chain
rule you could think of e to the FX as
this function right and so the
derivative of this is going to be F
prime of X that is the derivative of the
inside function times e to the F X and F
prime of X here if this is the inside
function is just k in other words the
derivative of KX is just k ok is that
clear okay well we will talk we can talk
about it after class will i'll show you
with the chain rule applying the chain
rule yes did you have your Henry's okay
oh there is a constant there has to be a
constant sorry this is plus C okay so
that's fair right okay and of course k
can't be 0 since division by 0 is not
allowed okay a couple of rules to keep
in mind
is the sum rule this is sort of what
you'd expect that is the integral for
some is just the sum of the integrals
and the constant multiple rule that is
the integral of a function times a
constant constant coefficient K is just
that constant coefficient times the
integral of the function in other words
you can take the K out of the integral
sign ok let's do an application I think
that that might help to fix ideas if we
think of oil consumption so remember
that the derivative is the speed and the
antiderivative is in some sense the area
ok and I want you to have in mind let's
see if I I don't think I did a picture
for you there ok I just want you to have
a picture in mind for this so let's read
the problem a little bit during the
early 1970s the annual worldwide rate of
oil consumption grew exponentially with
the growth constant of 0 point 0 7 so
that's about seven percent okay so you
could think about it as seven percent
annual growth at the beginning of 1970
the rate of consumption was sixteen
point 1 billion barrels annually okay so
january one 1970 the annual rate of
consumption is 16 point 1 billion
barrels per year and every moment it is
growing at the rate of seven percent per
year so at the end of nineteen seventy
it would have grown from 16.12 16.1
x 1 point 0 7 approximately right okay
so you could draw the following function
on the x axis I've got time and let's
say that starts at 1970 and at nineteen
seventy I know that the rate of
consumption was 16.1 okay and I know
that that rate of consumption is growing
exponentially at seven percent per annum
so when things grow exponentially it
usually looks like that okay it's okay
now it turns out that the area under
this curve this is the rate of
consumption as a function of time the
area under this curve is going to give
you the total consumption of oil since
1970 okay you could just imagine that if
you if i were to think of each of these
increments as one year then in the first
year approximately 16.1 barrels are
consumed in the next year 16.1 x 1 point
0 7 are consumed and then the third year
16.1 x 1 point 0 7 x 1 point 0 7 are
consumed and so on and i could add up
all those rectangles of course it's not
exactly that because the growth is
happening instantaneously that is it's
growing at seven percent per year but
it's not that it grows for seven percent
it's not growing in discrete time it's
growing instantaneously so that's why we
have
this function okay so you can imagine
certainly that the area under this curve
would approximate the total consumption
of oil up to whatever time T I had okay
so so let's let Artie denote the rate of
oil consumption at time T tease the
number of years since the beginning of
1970 so the function RT is just 16.1 e
to the point 0 7 t okay now if you let
capital t of t be the total oil consumed
from 1970 to time T that's just the area
under the graph and of course the area
under the graph total oil consumption to
daty you know that RT is the rate of
consumption per year remember what is a
rate a rate is probably a derivative of
something and it's going to be that the
rate is the derivative of the total
consumption so the rate is going to be
the derivative of the total consumption
okay okay another way to put it the
reverse way to put it is that the area
under this curve is given by capital T
ok as you increase t the rate is going
up and so is the area okay or you could
think of capital T as the antiderivative
of our okay so suppose what was our
question actually we don't have a
question but this is this is a way to to
Anna is the way for us to use the
antiderivative in a problem that one
might care about so I said capital T is
the antiderivative of our okay so that's
the same as saying that's the same as
saying that this is our I put it inside
the script s + DT so that's the
antiderivative this is the derivative
the rate now if I want to find out what
the total consumption at time period t
is I can take out this constant using
the rule that i just mentioned so i can
pull that 16.1 out of the integral 16.1
times the integral of this thing well
this you already know how to find the
antiderivative of what is this this is
just e to the K X right and what did we
say that was that was going to be
1 over K times e to the K X so that's 1
over K that's the K times e to the K X
the X in this case is T ok so that's so
once you worked out that antiderivative
and there's also the plus see once you
work out that antiderivative you can get
rid of the script s in the dt okay we've
found the integral and then you just
distribute the 16.1 and you get this so
the total consumption at time T is given
by this function now this is a class of
functions right this is not one function
it's a class of function I know that my
total consumption at time T has to have
this characteristic well I can find the
exact see that I that applies because I
happen to know that by definition this T
of 0 is going to be 0 what you know so
let's say that that t hat if I've set T
well I've got some definition of tea
right t is the number of years since the
beginning of 1970 right so when T is 0
that's 1970 and I care about total oil
consumption since 1970 so i know that in
nineteen seventy this function is equal
to 0 in other words this function is
equal to 0 in 1970 and in 1970 t is
equal little t is equal to zero so
that's equal to zero that's equal to 0 e
to the 0 is just 1 okay and so that's
going to be 230 plus c is equal to 0
ok and that's sorry that's another
problem so so by doing this I can work
out that C is minus 2 30 alright so T is
0 0 x 0 point 0 7 is 0 anything raised
to the power 0 is 1 so that's just 230
plus C is equal to 0 so c is equal to
minus 2 30 so what i really have this
function now I've now I no longer have a
class of functions I have a single
function that's see I've been able to
pin down exactly right so we have we're
not done yet that this is a function
that tells me that gives me the total
oil consumption from 1970 to any period
t okay and that's a function of T well
total amount of work that would have
been consumed from 1972 1980 tea would
be 10 years so I just plug in the value
10 into T so 10 times point 0 7 is 0
point 7 so the answers to 30 e to the
point 7 minus 2 30 and that happens to
be approximately 233 bout billion
barrels okay so you could think about it
in the following way remember we started
out in 1970 consuming 16 billion barrels
a year if we just consumed 16 billion
barrels of year for 10 years we would
have consumed 160 right but because we
have exponential growth by 19 let's say
this is 1980 we're at a significantly
higher number so it's not 16 times ten
at ten so it's not 160 but it turns out
to be 2 30 30 e is an actual number
it's approximately 2.7 one so it's in
your calculator right he is a constant
eat so he is a constant okay so actually
this is going to go first because I
think you understand integration now and
we're really going to talk about its
interpretation and in particular instead
of talking about the indefinite integral
will talk about the definite integral so
you see from that last application that
you can think of the integral as a
function that gives you the area under a
curve okay just like you could think of
the derivative as a function that gives
you the slope of a curve you can think
of the integral as a function that gives
you the area under a curve now often and
so in this case I was looking for the
area under the curve starting at zero
the indefinite integral will give you
the area under the curve for the entire
function often we want to know the area
under the curve for a particular segment
of the x-axis let's say from the value
of x equal to a to the value of x equal
to B we only want to know this area well
in principle what I could do is I could
work out the area under this curve from
minus infinity to be and then work out
the area under this curve from minus
infinity to a and take the difference
between the two and that's generally
what we do when we compute the definite
integral okay and so here I talk about
the Riemann sum approximation but
nothing here is more in depth than what
I already said so let's just skip that
so what's the definite integral it is
simply if I didn't have these a's and if
I didn't have this a and B you know what
this beast is it's simply the integral
of f of X that's the area under the
curve f of x from minus infinity to plus
infinity now if i put the integral from
A to B then that's like saying i want
the area under the curve from A to B if
I don't have the a and B it's from minus
infinity to plus infinity ok so the
definite integral is the limit of the
Riemann sum as those Delta X's go to 0
that's the width of those rectangles and
if FX is continuous and non-negative in
a B then the definite integral is the
area under the grub the thing that you
have to watch out for is that this is
non-negative if it were negative then
you'd have to switch some signs around
okay but it's helpful just to think of
it as a non negative function any time
you have a negative function you can
always convert it into a non negative 1
by multiplying by minus 1 which is a
constant which you can take out of the
integral and so on right okay now what's
the fundamental theorem of calculus it
sounds it sounds like a big deal but
actually it's it doesn't it doesn't look
as intimidating as it sounds this is the
fundamental theorem of calculus suppose
that little FX is a continuous function
on that interval a B
and suppose that big FX is its
antiderivative or is an antiderivative
then the definite integral from A to B
of little FX is simply the depth the
indefinite integral evaluated at B minus
the indefinite integral evaluated at a
ok that means you take the value of x
equal to B you plug it into the
indefinite integral and you take the
value of x equal to a you plug it into
the indefinite integral and you take the
difference between those two values what
happened to the constant of integration
here it will it disappeared right
because I could have had capital F of B
plus C minus capital f of a minus C so
the plus C in the minus C would cancel
out ok so the sea gets lost you think
about it in terms of this picture
remember I said I could take if I had
some function that described the area
under this graph and i called it capital
f of X I could evaluate it at the point
B which would be the area under the
curve from minus infinity to be and then
I could evaluate that function capital F
at the point a which would be the area
under the curve from minus infinity to a
take the difference between those two
and that's the area ok and that's
exactly what I'm doing with this
fundamental theorem of calculus
everybody see that ok I need you to get
this interpretation I don't care if you
don't know how to find an antiderivative
from a particular function ok ok